[SPEAKER_00]: Evening on the 27th of Flocktime, Jude and Horace leave the castle of the Earl of Redchor and head back into town.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, what did you think, Horace?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: An interesting man, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: It harks a little bit to his man-at-arms.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it's an old family.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I got the impression they were tied in with the Suleys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, apparently the Lord himself actually, some of his ancestors were, but I think they're holding on to greatness.
[SPEAKER_01]: He seems quite irritated with me when I mentioned that the poor princess
[SPEAKER_01]: That's interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't see why.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there is a war.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's so emphatically that the, uh, that, that Prince Jeon should take, uh, Coraxil seriously.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that's the thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it's well known that the, um, the kingdom of Keoland definitely looked unfavorably on slavery.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look unfavorably on slavery, however.
[SPEAKER_01]: What shocked me, well it didn't shock me I guess, what I took special note of simply was just that by his language when I talk with him alone it just seemed that he wanted to deal with the four princes specifically.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, Jeon and the Princess of Tipsum and the other four princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that he said then they would like deal with Toli but it almost sounded like he wanted to eradicate the four princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then somehow treats with Toli as if Toli is not the impetus behind maintaining slavery in the Seahawks.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know a little about the politics of the Seacrests.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, you must inform me.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are your thoughts here?
[SPEAKER_01]: My understanding is that, especially, I think that, alright, then
[SPEAKER_01]: In some considerable contact, as you might know after a year of hanging with Karmirg and Travis and myself, we had worked under Lord Seamus, who is tied in greatly with Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: And my understanding is, personally so, is that, especially Prince Jeon, the other princes have made more money since they've stopped pirating.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I must ask,
[SPEAKER_00]: Not the Prince of Monmurg, powerful enough to stop this crisis?
[SPEAKER_01]: I am not certain.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not sure that, especially when I'm certain of after seeing this blockade was why Prince Sion and the Princess tolerated the blockade of any kind and not sallied forth and parted.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what troubles me too.
[SPEAKER_00]: From what I understand,
[SPEAKER_00]: The Prince of Monmurg in his fleet is powerful.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably the most powerful on the Azura Sea, if not in this little day.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm equally shocked.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the way the hero of Gershore proclaims it is there's a state of war.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not just an embargo of certain stuff, trade stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a flat-out kind of cool-down embargo because of war.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are we to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we going to stay in this little fishing village?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, of course not.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have two options.
[SPEAKER_01]: The first is to get you and I to discuss before we left the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: I explained to the Earl that I was an envoy from the D, which very much so I am.
[SPEAKER_01]: He asked if I held any influence this way over, you know, any other in-course.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I said, simply that I would be treating, uh, with Laura Jamis, who is both poor and poorly, but that in the same way that I had gained audience with Earl.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would hope to gain audience with Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you can tell, I love Jamis pretty much.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in my discussion with him, he suggested that I should look for one individual, Owen Black, who, it seems, understands the full routes of clothes and is somewhat of a smuggler.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume would be the premature hero.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps even higher than the hero.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, we are speaking now from this oven rock and my understanding if we head to any of the named pubs and perhaps ask or use a little bit of a coin, we could probably find out who he is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Although, in truth, I am worried about bringing an assassin to Old Seamus' buried hillside, so I'm not entirely sure if we do get a smuggler to guide us through.
[SPEAKER_01]: I still think that if the merchants want to go, we can take the smuggler if he agrees on our ship, pay Balut, and have him guide Balut through the mines.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, once we're Monmurg,
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, do you think the man would, um, need to have, uh, even an acquaintance with Lord Janus?
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm worried about is that we go to the Earl of Redforge Nightman, and that he kills us and takes whatever money you have.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is true enough and probably if he wanted to take in everything on our ship as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why is it that he gave you this information?
[SPEAKER_01]: I simply entreated with him as Olymcom E.D., and when he asked who I would entreat with in Monmurg, and I said Lord Jamis was paying over the foreign quarter, I think he was trying to enlist me as a spy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said that he would pay handsomely for any information or insight into the mind of Lord Jamis, and by extension Prince Jehon.
[SPEAKER_01]: And furthermore, he seemed to intimate that
[SPEAKER_01]: Either that or an opportunist.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think I see what he's doing now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically you are a long shot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aye, but that would assume that they're having some troubles.
[SPEAKER_01]: And apparently the Sea Princess haven't found a report, which yet, as you admitted, is a huge mystery to both of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that we have to scheme a court of Monmurg for ourselves.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I approach that with some trepidation.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they have troubles, we will see those troubles with dark sails in the harbor.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's my suspicion.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, do you trust Lucille and Black?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you trust this suggestion?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is there some other course you'd like to take?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, as I see it, we either head back to the Loot and press upon the entrance to swing around the wide seas around Chesson Island, try to approach Monmurg from the south and hoping that there's no blockade in the lower bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or we slay Lord Dreadshore's camel and perhaps see what might unfold.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm tempted to
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there's no trouble, I mean, there's no risk in meeting the man, I assume.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or at least a little.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, um...
[SPEAKER_00]: It is as you said, if the Earl wanted to do us harm, he would have done it to us in his own castle.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he could have easily done it.
[SPEAKER_01]: True.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll cover your back, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I can... enslave many things for our craft.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so we go to probably, I'm guessing, one of the finer establishments on the beach, or at least one of the ones with slightly more luxurious company.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, so you travel back to the city through the night, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And reach the outskirts of the town, which is, you know, as I've said before, obviously a fishing slash whaling town.
[SPEAKER_00]: With little use for deep docks for trading.
[SPEAKER_00]: And again, you shake your head as to wondering why somebody would think that this would match the docks of Monmurg, which are at least 20 times greater in both their efficiency and their size.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're like, wow, these 40 ships probably would already have been unloaded in their cargo in the great market.
[SPEAKER_01]: And just a day.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, you walk into town, and do you want to walk alongside the shoreline, or what do you want?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to go in a little bit more where I can see where, you said that there were a lot of temporary places that are along the shoreline.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to see if there's more established taverns and bars.
[SPEAKER_01]: In this place to maybe find a smuggler.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, what it is is kind of strange because along the shoreline there are like obviously places like fish markets, stuff like that, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But many of them have kind of been converted into makeshift open air inns.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it just seems like any old
[SPEAKER_00]: Merchants or, you know, rogues can put a keg of ale down on the beach and sell it for whatever he wants.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're like parties of people sitting around at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically like Teggers, with people charging money for Teggers, or even merchants just walking up and down the beach with, you know, carts with barrels of ale and so on, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, we'll approach one of the merchants with the, uh, perhaps, like, we'll pay to eat with some wine, or, uh, just something such as, like, you know, snow, like, vodka, and, um, just try to purchase from him
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you go up to one of the merchants, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just randomly, or is there any kind of look you want?
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like a little bit...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so there's a guy with kind of a cart.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he looks, what I would say is, he's definitely a Radiant, but he looks, his clothing and dress are a little bit different than what the Red Shorians are wearing, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: They wear very drab kind of looking clothes.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy has a little bit more finery, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And he has actually two guards by his guard that seem well-armed, wearing breastplates and, you know, with swords on them.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have some libations, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at you and he says, Quite certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: What would you like, my friend?
[SPEAKER_00]: I have yellow wine from the Stingriff Isles, if that interests you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You look like a man of means.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have recently come across from the eastern shores of the azure something from the west.
[SPEAKER_01]: Local, but still exclusive.
[SPEAKER_00]: From the west.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the cinder clouds are from the east, my friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: But please, try this.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he goes over to a very small keg and puts a little bit of a yellow liquid in a crystal glass and says, taste it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very refreshing.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's called Chardonnay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I give it a good sniff and hand that glass over to another one for myself, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you like your entire glass, my friend?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a silver coin per glass.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yes, most certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's two silvers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely, and like he pours two of them.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, I must say, you are my most discerning customer.
[SPEAKER_00]: He gives you each a glass and says,
[SPEAKER_00]: You'd be surprised what these foolish yokels think or drink here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I must say, Cullen Moore is the most puss-bram.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have never been here before and to be fair, I'm surprised that our ship has been loaded to Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Quite the surprise, quite the surprise.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me as well, I think.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I was in Monmurg, I'd be selling my wares right and left.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, we're forced to stop here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought I would at least try to make a little money as I were here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, these Luffians will drink fermented fish water if they could get their hands on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you a merchant?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nay, nay, I'm an ambassador from the, the, uh, the embattled countries, the, well, country of the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems like they have lost some of their allies in the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I've heard some rumor of the puddle wave that ravaged that coast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, much, much more, said the locals.
[SPEAKER_01]: Only, uh, surpassed by the prism of the South Province and was opportunistic.
[SPEAKER_00]: I apologize for the troubles that your nation has endured.
[SPEAKER_00]: I ask, what did you come this side of the world for?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, to and straight, of course, but the secret is that if their money and funds and some investment or interest that they might have...
[SPEAKER_01]: To assist Edie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tribulations follow you, my friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: Edie must be... Edian ruins and now this cursed war between the three principalities in Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: This war, there's nothing other ways to describe it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yet Monmurg fleets us not sally forth and destroy the Keolandish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I look around, and those just respect any Keoland-ish that might be the same hearing, but I'm surprised that there's been no mention of any resistance from the Sea Princess.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is my mind, too.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'll tell you, I've been here a week, seeing that this cursed war would lift, and the Monmurgians would sally forth, as you say, and yet they have not.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know how much longer I can wait myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is much... much...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll tell you a rumor I heard, my friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it will only cost you, say, who pulls out a bottle of Chardonnay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Say you purchase this bottle, my friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wonderful.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two gold coins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, actually, that's not right.
[SPEAKER_00]: One gold coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he basically says to you, and he says, there's a rumor that there's a sea monster that patrols the islands near the scimitars outside of Monmurg, and that any ship from the Sea Principalities that tries to go north of the strait will be attacked, specifically the fleet.
[SPEAKER_00]: They say some sorcerer has befuddled its mind and set it against Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, like I said, it's a rumor and only true, but it's one that's been told to me several times.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why not have many of the merchants out who just arrived some near six, eight hours ago and saw all these ships in the bay?
[SPEAKER_01]: The bay cannot handle this level of commerce.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why not have some of them broken to go around just some islands to the north and therefore perhaps avoid the Seamoss or even the Ruminants?
[SPEAKER_01]: And pass by the Dragon Isles?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you insane?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not a merchant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, from what I understand, the Dragon Isles are populated by dragon turtles that use it as basically their hunting grounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not usually dangerous, especially because the Prince of Monmurg pays them a stipend of treasure every year.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, merchants dare not go that way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, of course, to the north, if we go that way, we will be escorted all the way to Grapple.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm, yes, I simply was wondering.
[SPEAKER_01]: Being an uninitiative, you know, of the seas, and completely ignorant of its tides, I simply look at a map and I say, why not go around?
[SPEAKER_01]: But, as you say, I suppose these turtles is not a problem?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, in truth, what I was thinking is that if this deceasement lasts much longer, I will turn my ship and maybe go to Gradville to trade.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's tragic.
[SPEAKER_01]: There is so much prince to be made in Monmurg, especially with a blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: True, true, but if there's a war going on and we go into Monmurg, who's to say we can get back out?
[SPEAKER_00]: And I've heard other rumors as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: You wanna buy another bottle?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you say, I have another one of those bottles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, because you're most generous, my friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: There are pirates about.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pirates that do not work.
[SPEAKER_00]: For the Sea Princes, but actually work for Keoland, apparently.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not two weeks ago they attacked Port Torvin and burned it to the ground.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, yes, by the mouth of the Houle River.
[SPEAKER_00]: They destroyed the town and killed every man and woman and child.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at this man of arms.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they completely impassive?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they nodding?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or are they like they've heard the same thing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, they're on guard.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not saying anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's not like they're denying this stuff with him, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're just at attention watching.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then what's worse?
[SPEAKER_00]: There was a supply of food coming from the yeomanry to feed the people of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was all burnt and so the city has no supplies.
[SPEAKER_00]: They get no trade from the east and also there are pirates to the west making sure that no food rushes in.
[SPEAKER_00]: This would seem
[SPEAKER_00]: Look, a trifling, in my mind, for the lords of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, for some reason, the Toli are stingy with their food.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not the Tuli.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is as I said.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most of the citizens are.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the Tuli are aligned in all ways.
[SPEAKER_01]: Regardless of their hatred of each other or their competition.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're Tuli birds.
[SPEAKER_01]: All foreigners.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is what has come to my mind as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are other strange things occurring around these lands.
[SPEAKER_01]: The washing of the land with the tidal wave.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems that things are afoot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Changing rapidly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Substantially now things are changing in Selenmore as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Selenmore has been a land long thought to be lost.
[SPEAKER_00]: A land of plague from the marches.
[SPEAKER_00]: A land of ghosts.
[SPEAKER_00]: A land of werewolves necessarily.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kind of a wild land where the
[SPEAKER_00]: Rivals to the Rola, the House of Rola in Gradsul, died many years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know not much about the history, but they say the Duke of Rola has appointed a Plar in the city of Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Plar means to do war with those in the marsh.
[SPEAKER_00]: So war is afoot in these lands.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Ghul Marshes?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Ghul Marshes, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Klaar has been given license to go into the Hul and attack the Flannock there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's some religious group in that marsh called something like the Sons of Olag.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what I've heard lately is that the Klaar has won a great victory against them.
[SPEAKER_00]: This just happened recently.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe a fortnight hence.
[SPEAKER_01]: I found this
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have another bottle?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're buying three bottles?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I'm buying three bottles.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm looking for one Owen Black, who I have heard since my arrival here might have some knowledge of the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you describe the man to me?
[SPEAKER_01]: I did not say smuggler.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just said that he knew of the, uh, the points about, uh, La Hague.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're staying by a smoker, so if you want to say that, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, well, I think he's smart enough to kind of pick up on what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, I suggest you go to the whale.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he points down the, the, um, uh, pier about, I would say 200 feet, to like a place that looks pretty raucous.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are a lot of people outside it talking and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes,
[SPEAKER_00]: There are a lot of what I would call sailors and... rogues, so to speak, from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that's what you want to find, is it not?
[SPEAKER_01]: I believe so.
[SPEAKER_01]: And your expertise, no matter how limited, but your time on these shores makes you my savior.
[SPEAKER_01]: I appreciate any suggestions that you might have.
[SPEAKER_01]: The whale, is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: The whale, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I appreciate, actually, your, um...
[SPEAKER_00]: Generosity.
[SPEAKER_00]: I must say, this was a good sale today.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fine wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Greatly appreciated.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have not tasted this wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're welcome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here you go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so you know where to start walking down the street.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're basically carrying these three bottles of wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess you want to put them in your pack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at Horace.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you use a microphone?
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't think it was too bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: He said, no, it's actually very good.
[SPEAKER_00]: It didn't have any dirt in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: It had no...
[SPEAKER_00]: It didn't taste like...
[SPEAKER_00]: It didn't taste like iodine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, let's say it was very sweet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sweeter than my taste for most wines, but still good.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: To the letter.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so you guys walk down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And let me check something.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have, okay, we still have seven minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm going to do after this session ends is I will just restart it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I need to log out and then log back in?
[SPEAKER_00]: You will be logged out, but then you can use the same link and it should just restart.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, so what I mean is that I can still stay in the game, the stone game?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, Journey of the Stone you can definitely be in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then leave the chat open, and there'll be another prompt that shows me to click onto the Zoom screen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it'll be the same prompt.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm saying is, when I say go for it, in the Journey of the Stone, you can just bring up the link that I've already sent you, and you should be rejoined.
[SPEAKER_00]: If that doesn't work, I'll just send you a new link.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you walk down to the whale, and it's as the man said, I mean it's pretty late, it's about now, it's about 10.30, but you can tell this sleepy little coastal town has a lot more people, like I said, in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it is, and there are people that are like, there are traders out there trying to trade, with a small amount of wares at all hours, there are like,
[SPEAKER_00]: You see Toli Raps walking around.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see people that like look like they're from both the sea principalities and Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: You also see like Keogh Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, like military guys that are on, that are kind of off duty.
[SPEAKER_00]: All kind of fraternizing.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, you would think that actually many of these guys would be fighting if they met on the sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's like a mishmash of what's going on here.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's almost like a truce of Harvard or a truce of Iran?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, maybe it's that, or maybe it's that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there may be some understanding that since Monmurg hasn't sallied forth, there's no reciprocal state of war.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Keoghs feel like they're in control, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the Monmurgians are just waiting for a statement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or, what's happening is the Monmurgians that you're seeing here and the guys from Port Toli, maybe they're looking for work on Keogh ships.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, because they don't have any work on their own.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, I go in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any table to be seen?
[SPEAKER_01]: And if not, I try to get the notice of a bar patron and ask for a table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so basically this is like an open-air garage.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's basically an open place with like a covering over it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's exactly what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Open to the night air.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the people are just kind of milling about.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are some, like, stools and seats basically made out of tree stumps or driftwood that are, you know, by the bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: But for the most part, people are just kind of milling around talking, you know, and carousing.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we either try to, you know, find that place where Horace and I can, you know, have a little bit of elbow room at some place, either at the bar or if there's like a standing table, you know, that's, you know, just high or whatever or, you know, if there's a regular table that we can fit for two or for four, it doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you can go right up to the bar if you would like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, of course, we will.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we will order.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I don't have any glass and, you know, I'm not drinking right out of the bottle of one of my wines.
[SPEAKER_00]: My kid used some crad, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's more than one person here drinking right out of the bottle, but it's not wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you guys go up to the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, um, basically a bar dade comes up and says, what can I get the two of you?
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, I'll have an ale.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm breaking glass.
[SPEAKER_01]: I actually have my own drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd prefer to drink it out of the glass clean, preferably.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, no cans, no hard grip on the inside.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm so happy to pay for the comfort as is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, aren't you fancy?
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, unfortunately no glass here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you take a mug?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I... And we're waiting for a friend, Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: I owe him a good amount of drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a deception roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that's, uh...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I'm gonna go over to the dice one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that a G20?
[SPEAKER_00]: G20, and let me look at your character.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I don't have deception skill.
[SPEAKER_01]: I traded that out for history.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, so it's based on your charisma.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, this is...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a negative, but it's not a positive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: 12.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, she says, well, I know that blabber.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's right over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, she's working.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: She works with a guy that's basically over in the corner and a table with like these...
[SPEAKER_00]: What looked to be like two Toli rats, you know, kind of Suel-Oeridian mix, and then somebody that looks like an Oeridian sailor as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Give him a mug of the same thing that my friend Forrest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just selling compliments for our sails.
[SPEAKER_00]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys go and sit down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, that sounds good.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll keep my eye on them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, we're about to lose each other, alright?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you're going to text me, go for it, and then I'll click on... Yeah, I'll restart the meeting and then say go for it, all right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: You there?
[SPEAKER_01]: You there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, this actually works very well.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can use the, uh, we can use Zoom for audio.
[SPEAKER_01]: Great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so, uh, yeah, so I just asked for it to, uh, double check, you know, like to kind of watch his associates, since we've kind of tagged him first, so to speak, and, uh, let's see if he comes over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I left, you know, 15 seconds
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean basically you see the serving maid go over there and put the ale down and then she points you out as if she's done this before, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like it's not uncommon practice.
[SPEAKER_01]: I raise my cup and acknowledge me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I'm drinking from the flagon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so he does look over you and kind of sees who you are and raises his mug to you, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you see him drink it down like he drinks it all, okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: And puts it down and kind of stands up and walks over to where you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he says, hey there now, I think you have me at a disadvantage, my friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm Owen Black, who are you?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm Jude, and this is my associate, uh, Forks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please, have a seat, I'm happy to buy you another drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: You come highly recommended, uh, from the highest local authority.
[SPEAKER_00]: A Jew, huh?
[SPEAKER_00]: And who would that be, might I ask?
[SPEAKER_01]: He lives across that watery bay in that rear large structure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, no need to speak any further.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he wouldn't send you my way unless you had requests, as it were.
[SPEAKER_01]: So she brings it over and goes, Thank you kindly, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems like you throw coin around without much regard.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we can do business.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is it that you like?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I see what you are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this comes after I had treated with a man in the Missouri abode.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Usually he wants a different kind of cargo delivered, but... Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do come with the ship, provided that the others on board are willing to make the run.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it would be advantageous to me if they decided to make the run.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, we lose the rest of the series concerns.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make the run?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you misunderstand what I do, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not a pilot, per se, for hire, and I doubt there's a ship in the bay that could make the run besides my own, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many people do you want to come with us?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you ever guide more than your own ship or simply your own ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the truth is that my little sloop is fairly swift and I know the routes of all the patrols and I know the flags to use if you mess it up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I've paid hands here and there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think what I should say is, if you want transport to where I think you want, it can't be too many people, and it has to be on my ship, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, maybe it's going to be two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Steve, you're very faint to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, uh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: How does this sound?
[SPEAKER_01]: Better.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's better.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it would have to be two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two is very fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just the two of you?
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a ship that I hoped to bring with, but it was full of merchants with starry eyes looking to make three times the profit for our charter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and that ship is traveling from Red Shore to...
[SPEAKER_00]: The peninsula, if you get my meaning.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact...
[SPEAKER_01]: I do, I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, you can only make the journey in nights.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm, are you able to cross the bay in one single night?
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me see about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, each square is 5 miles, 5, 10, 15, 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, each square is 5 miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: 35, so about 35 miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, I can get you there by morning if you left tonight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, that will cost you extra money if you wish to go...
[SPEAKER_01]: So what do you charge for passengers with food?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, if you wish to go tonight, it would cost you quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: 50 each, 100 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you're willing to wait a few days...
[SPEAKER_00]: Would be less, maybe fifteen, twenty, depending on how many I could muster.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not worth my time, you understand, unless there's a hundred gold coins in it for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hm, of course, of course, I certainly can understand that.
[SPEAKER_01]: When would we leave if we leave tonight?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I have an hour to prepare myself and are you docked at any place?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, if we leave in an hour, I can get you to Ensar, Senar.
[SPEAKER_00]: If that's good for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ensar?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, hang it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: A little fishing village, maybe, I would say, 30 miles from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: That sounds good.
[SPEAKER_01]: So for a hundred gold, what he's saying is he can get me to Imstar by first dawn, first light, roughly?
[SPEAKER_00]: Around morning time, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we would leave in an hour.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, can I get back to the loose and withdraw my other many funds and or box of items from the loose?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, easily, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And get back and ready to leave?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, when I say, um, I always hated waiting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have a coin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Excuse me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have a coin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look in my bag and I pull out the three bottles of wine and put them on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you require visual proof?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Meet me on the dock.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, maybe 300 feet, I mean 300 yards down.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see, you see that red lantern down there?
[SPEAKER_00]: He basically points out into the night and there's like a, a dog out there with a red lantern hanging off one of the hooks above it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, alright, yes, yes, I see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, you see it, couldn't you?
[SPEAKER_00]: My sleuth is there.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's his other name?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bad luck, you see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Once you name a ship or a woman, she's gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or maybe she never leaves.
[SPEAKER_00]: He kind of laughs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here he goes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I guess the woman never leaves.
[SPEAKER_00]: The suit goes away.
[SPEAKER_01]: By the Red Lantern, it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: In an hour.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that I will make see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so what do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, so what I want to do is, I want to double check with Horace what his vibes were, what he thought the Toli rafts did, or the other Oeridian, you know, where they like, did they follow us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so basically Horace gets back up, I mean not Horace, but Owen Black gets back up and walks back over to this table, as if he was just saying hello, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, that's correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you say, what about his companions, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: My impressions of the two Toli are drinking partners for tonight, nothing more than that.
[SPEAKER_00]: The other man watched us briefly but seemed to know what was happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably one of his crew.
[SPEAKER_01]: Geez, I have not lived all these years in the company of gals in Keoland, Erkin.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a fit to be prepared for Skull Ventures.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I can hear you.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just make sure I don't lose it walking around.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's kind of faint.
[SPEAKER_00]: When you walk away, is this like a wireless headset?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, no, it's, I'm still plugged in, but I, uh, maybe, maybe it's, maybe...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think when the wire gets to a particular position, we might lose a little signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just tell me, though, and I can adjust it on my head.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's really good right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, good, good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I did was that my youngest son uses his headphones, so I don't think that I actually adjusted them down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I think the mic was pointed at the nose.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was on the mouth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so we will take a boat back to the loot in order to get the rest of our baggage and the rest of our coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm not keeping super-duper tight track of my coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Should I be?
[SPEAKER_01]: You said I had a thousand.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm keeping track of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You had about a thousand gold coins, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had taken 500 and left 500.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I left, like, my wine and Celine and some of the others.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your crates and everything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, of course, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I would like to go back and check those.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, we'll have to maybe address the captain just out of politeness when we get on that one here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you take the longboat back out.
[SPEAKER_00]: That takes you about 15 minutes, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the two of you basically get off.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to say to the longboat men?
[SPEAKER_01]: Remain here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We will be putting our things on board, and we will be going back to shore imminently.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long?
[SPEAKER_01]: Give us 15 minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: For us here, we'll be loading the goods on board while I stop the captain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so I tell Horace to go ahead and unload the things, make sure he knows where the, I mean he knows where the coinage was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's like, I'll get our packs, I'll clean our rooms.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, and I go to talk with the captain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the captain basically is still on deck, and I believe it's probably around 11 now, and you come, you basically come up to him and say, oh, you're back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Captain, good sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've learned quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems like no one is getting through the Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I've even heard rumors while I was on shore of some creatures in the fall.
[SPEAKER_01]: My best suggestion to you and for fellow mercenaries on board is to either sail here at what advantage they can, or to sail up the grassland.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there's no chance this war will end?
[SPEAKER_01]: Apparently not.
[SPEAKER_01]: A poor children by rumors say has been burned and raised to the ground.
[SPEAKER_01]: Every man, woman, and child killed.
[SPEAKER_00]: That seems strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was this by a ground force?
[SPEAKER_01]: I know not.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've spoken to a few captains.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Dragon Isles are a known danger.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think no man would go within ten miles of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, strangely enough, I talked to many of the captains and what they told me is they were hoping at some point the Monmurgans would lift the blockade.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know not why.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will be disembarking here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have, in good faith, my coinage.
[SPEAKER_01]: I trust that you have deserved this entirety.
[SPEAKER_01]: I seek to venture forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I will not be able to get to Monmurg, but I can make the shore in the south, and I will inquire into why sequences have allowed this blockade to hold.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I can't say this is the best news, but at least it's some news, and it will help me make my decision.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you think that you will still try to risk running the blockade?
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, I'm unsure.
[SPEAKER_00]: In truth, I would try to run the blockade to Monmurg if there were any sign that the Monmurgians were sallying forth or making any attempt to challenge the Keogh Navy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I agree, I agree.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was my hope to take your cargo and your merchants and see many times the value in a blockade at Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it sounds like traveling east is perhaps not viable.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yet, traveling south directly to one blockade, it's a very narrow strait.
[SPEAKER_01]: In Keoland, if Monmurg is not out in the forest, and Keoland does indeed have those slaves who are hidden, I may not be safe.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a risk I would not have to take, at least not on my side.
[SPEAKER_01]: As an envoy from UD, I must, of course, seek any possible route for which I will not be able to take Monmurg unless
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I must say you're very gracious.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please, if you are what you say you are, ambassador, so to speak, entreat for Prince Jeon, or at least some of his advisors, to have this farce lifted.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will, completely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, in fact, the very survival of the PD depends upon it.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need this route open for supplies to make it back.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no question.
[SPEAKER_01]: We will do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll then go in peace.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Safe travels.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I hope you have safe travels yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: I, you know, give them a good firm handshake.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like to, as a character, just note any of the traders.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, not if there's like ten different traders, but if there's like two or three different merchants that have trade goods on the hold, and the captain, and of course the name of the ship, I just kind of commit it to memory.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll say that if you see any of these persons, you can definitely do an in-check to see if you recognize them in the future.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's not a very difficult in-check.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it's a year from now, it might be difficult, but basically, you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, just simply because, you know, if I see him at a foreign court and I need help, I might ask for it, or if I'm like, hey, if I could benefit from you shipping this there, blah, blah, blah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just want to make a note to the DM.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to make sure that I know faces, and kind of like what they deal in, and obviously the captain, person A, person A of the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll go ahead and just, I'll make sure I take
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: I still think that was a beautiful idea.
[SPEAKER_01]: Run it up in the morning, see if Kermit's drinking now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that was a beautiful idea.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm all like, those fuckers, I wouldn't lie to the pastor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just counting shifts, going like, this one's gonna break first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, okay, so I get my goods, uh, everything's there, no problem, Boris is like, we got it all?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, basically it's all, it all gets floated on the, um, longboat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, um, you guys cast off from the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: And do you want to row directly to the port?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yeah, I would say, uh, well, what I would say is, uh, give us within like a couple, I don't know if they call it a quay, but like a pier or a couple piers of the sloops, so we don't need to go to the place we were last at and left from.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, you can go right up to the, the, uh, sloops pier itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you want to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we'll do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you take a long boat and, um,
[SPEAKER_00]: Within 15 minutes, so this is like 45 minutes after you talked to Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so we're getting close to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: So when we get close, it's, you know, hail aboard kind of thing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you come up to dock, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the longboat comes up next to it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the guy jumps out and basically ties off the longboat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, Owen Black, who's on the other side of the pier, his ship is on the other side of the pier.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is a small ship, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, like a one-mast?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a one-mast ship, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's some jibs in front so you can navigate.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, um, it's got like a cabin in back.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this, it's like the steered is actually pretty high off the ground for a ship this small.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: It looks like it's fairly fast.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like a Monmurgian...
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at Horace and she kind of gives me the lines, like the kind of the... Like, does she tell me it looks pretty fast?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you say, what do you think?
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, I don't see whether enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wouldn't call it a lowly cutter, but I think it will cut through the ocean quite fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: And quickly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, this man looks to be a definite blockade runner.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm nodding my head, enough said.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so you guys get off and unload stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and I give the look to Horace when I say, you know, rest until we make landfall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so, Owen is standing there and he goes, And I'm like, drink nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: What about water?
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless you have it on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, okay, I understand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so Owen Black is like standing there and he goes,
[SPEAKER_00]: Come up, my friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: You come up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, and he goes, you two, help with their crates.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got a little bit of bat water in my fingers.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so the two of you clamber up onto the deck.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what you notice when you get up on the deck is the deck
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, looks strange because it looks like it's kind of been burnt.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, the mask itself looks like it has some black scorches on it as if something had burnt it in the past.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, this damage is what I would call, uh...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys get on board.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, I don't know how that happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's strange to me, friend, I'll tell you a tale.
[SPEAKER_00]: This ship was stolen from me some months back, and it came back into my possession.
[SPEAKER_00]: These stars were on it afterwards.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know how that happened, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: I have more than one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, I'm not that funny.
[SPEAKER_00]: But my fault.
[SPEAKER_00]: Speaking of benefits...
[SPEAKER_01]: The gray wrist makes me nervous.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have the coin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Speaking of benefits, I have here about 50 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume that you would like at least half complimentary.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other half, when my feet touch dry land,
[SPEAKER_00]: And he says, that's fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume you do have that, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: In your possession.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of like, shake the other coin.
[SPEAKER_01]: I make sure, sorry, I make sure that I have the 50 and 50 divided up so he's not like, he might be taking out like, you know, 50 gold coins out of a thousand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Out of a thousand, yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I gotta do that, 50-50.
[SPEAKER_01]: I shake the one as I hand it to him, I shake the other three.
He's like,
[SPEAKER_01]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll give me the coin when we get off the coast of Inksar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Provided I can swim if you throw me overboard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, don't worry, we're not going to throw you overboard, but we're not going to dock.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll take a little boat to the beach and then drop you there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so real quick notes to the DM.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I need to be dragging the donkey along on this thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, how much luggage do I have?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, you have a crate of wine, and your pack, and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, like, I can't, like, ask course to grab a fucking crate of wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, like, Ensar is a town, so if we were able to get our, like, a boat, like a longboat to shore, and we unload...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you travel to Port Calm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, which is to the south of Monmurg a little bit, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: You've been there one time before.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically to find Gouge and Karmirg in one of the drunken binges where you had to pick them up because for some reason they wanted to go to Port Combe.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of those drink and whore in Port Combe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: They wanted to go see the countryside basically, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: How likely is it though I should be able to get a mule?
[SPEAKER_01]: Present in this scene.
[SPEAKER_00]: Present in this scene.
[SPEAKER_00]: So anyway, you get on the boat, you give, you throw him the 50 gold coins, and he, he says thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I shake, right, and I shake my bag, make sure he knows, like, the weight or the sound of the coins together for the other 50.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, uh, I make sure that the whore stays awake and doesn't drink anything that's separate from his own canteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, and basically, Owen Black says, where do you wish to, um, sleep?
[SPEAKER_00]: You can go below if you'd like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I won't be sleeping, sorry, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you're welcome to stay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where are you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you're welcome to stay on the steerage with me if you'd like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, the sailors, and they're like maybe four guys, that's all, on the fleet, skillfully basically take the sails, bring them up, and then the ship starts to move out.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're actually a little concerned about maneuvering through this traffic.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like driving through a parking lot where the cars are parked haphazardly in all directions.
[SPEAKER_00]: But Owen proves to be a very good navigator.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're actually kind of impressed by his skill of weaving between the dozens of ships that block the bay between the island of Red Shore and the mainland.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: And, um...
[SPEAKER_01]: Before long... Are we heading deeper into the bay, like from that, towards Angler Island?
[SPEAKER_01]: You go this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you see the red mark?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so you basically go out and by, um...
[SPEAKER_00]: So you got to his docks by, I'd say, about 12 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we have about a six hour journey to get through 35 miles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, in... You're moving around, I would say... Three knots as you go through the bay and get to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Knots is a nautical mile?
[SPEAKER_00]: Knots is a nautical mile.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then when you get to here, he opens it up, and actually you guys start moving around 4.5 knots.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: So, let me do some... My intellect, you know, I always love learning things, so what I would say is it would be nice if I just noted, like, how fast can small shit with one hand crew go?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think any of the rest of you have ever been.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: You basically go out into the water and probably within the first 30 minutes you're in open sea and you see the likes of Angler Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently there's another village on that island over there to the west as you start heading south.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does the blockade extend this far west into the bay?
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, basically he says, there's not much west of Angler Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can get to Saltmarsh, but Saltmarsh, even though it does have docks, is not much of a trading town.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I hear the new lord of Saltmarsh is trying to make docks for trade.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm a rumor about the sea monsters keeping the sea princes locked up in the straits.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've heard that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, there's a pause.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he look at least uncomfortable?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he look like he's about to lie?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he... No, he looks like he's a little knowing of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like it might be true?
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe, but like he's not, he didn't really say anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're just rumors.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm bad at sea turtles.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think personally if there is, if there is anything true to that rumor, it is one of the sea turtles from Dragon Isles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, uh, hence dropping me off in N-Soc.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have gone past the Dragon Isles of late and I'll tell you this.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are strange storms in the sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, not long ago there was a mist that covered the bay between here and Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: It looked kind of like a hurricane, but it was too shallow a sea to be in, strangely enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, I must ask your opinion, and feel free to ignore me should your requirements as a ship's captain force you to focus on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why has the Sea Princess not shattered the slowlandish fleet?
[SPEAKER_01]: We all know that they could, or at least they could a year ago, ere I left Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I am no citizen in truth.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a very large mystery.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that the rumors of the Seamonster may be a bit true.
[SPEAKER_00]: The rumor is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Prince of Monmurg has not paid his yearly tribute to the Dragon Isle Dragons.
[SPEAKER_01]: And hence they've out-liked themselves with stolen?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're just restless, taking vengeance on the Monmurgian fleet.
[SPEAKER_01]: And perhaps Keolanders are taking advantage of that restlessness?
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very safe, very safe.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have come to entreat that the Princess of Monmurg, and the Sea Princess, provide us a help with
[SPEAKER_01]: Indeed, the country that I come from, which is a very big strata, I would have thought they would have easily paid any sum to the Dragon Isles for secure trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you come to a trade with who?
[SPEAKER_01]: The sea princesses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everyone knows that they have great money and perhaps, you know, states you would deal with endeavors.
[SPEAKER_01]: A.D. is having been beset by that great tidal wave a year ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's been devastated.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the South Province has declared war on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I, your humble envoy, is coming to seek some sort of financial support and trade for whatever we may offer.
[SPEAKER_01]: True.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, he's all looks at you for a second.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says...
[SPEAKER_01]: Seriously.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he says...
[SPEAKER_01]: I feel as if I know you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do an in-check.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a DC-15 in-check.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: So I do a DC 20, but I gotta get over 15?
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you get your pluses for intelligence, which is plus 4.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so here we go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, fuck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so it's only 5.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's only 9.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at him and I say...
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless... you... know one gouge... of karma...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would not know you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do another insight roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: A 20?
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll a 20?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, a 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: A 25 die?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He gets a look of fear in his eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he goes, you know, for a second, he goes, ah, seeing no god, Jay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that for anybody who's anybody?
[SPEAKER_01]: No gals?
Obviously he knows.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, I didn't know you were a friend of the captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that what he said, a friend of the captain?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's so shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't say friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't say that he has anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm pretty sure you felt that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, just so, just so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, well that's interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perhaps you can put a good word in for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I certainly will.
[SPEAKER_01]: You tell me what should be said.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I've got a couple scores to settle with on a personal note.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing, of course, that involves death.
[SPEAKER_01]: But good, strong crashes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess you're a more important man than I thought.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not going to ask me if I'm more than a hundred, are you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no, no, no, absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's good to know that you actually seem more important than I thought.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, working for it and working on it... Has a mark.
Has a mark.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, he basically kind of falls quiet at that point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll step in one of my wine bottles of Chardonnay and offer him a glass and sip from it first, of course, from the bottle before I pour him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would you care to press 8?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I sip from it first, of course, so... Not until we'll touch dangerous waters.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so basically, you and Horace, and Owen Black, he's got his three men basically down in, on the, um, uh, deck, uh, and you feel through the night, and you don't want to sleep, Horace is alert, and you guys basically just go, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so, basically, uh, are you doing still?
[SPEAKER_00]: Peace.
Thank you for watching!
[SPEAKER_01]: Stay on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thanks for watching!
Present in this scene...
[SPEAKER_00]: You there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, you got me now?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I got you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, my son is taller than me.
At 14?
He's 13.
[SPEAKER_01]: He'll be 14 in April.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's 8th grade.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's getting ready to go into college.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're working out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I still remember how seriously used up working out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not trying to do anything crazy.
[SPEAKER_01]: For me, I'm just trying not to be all bald and fat, but for him, I'm just trying to get him used to a sort of...
[SPEAKER_01]: Physical day?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I've always admired how you did that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember...
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember you, even before you were in Selma, when you were working out, I'm not...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a totally ghetto place.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that was a, that was a good thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, living down, I can't remember the name of that house.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't remember that house, but I remember that, that for me was the first time when you were like, you had like your dad would set up a pulley and just a big bench, and I was like, damn dude, I'm all fucking serious.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that was good.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't work out like that anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got to say, actually, I took this new job at Intel, and it's been a really tough three and a half years, three years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well, it totally will.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm probably right now about 20 pounds overweight, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm 30 pounds and I never had to watch that, so maybe we're not the same.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's funny because I still go walking and stuff, but I think the thing I miss the most is up until I joined Intel, I was swimming quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would go swimming at least two or three times a week depending on what the deal was.
[SPEAKER_00]: We had a neighborhood pool.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was nice to be out but you know it's funny because the year before I went to Intel it just got zooed out there was just too many people there and it got spotty and then after I went to Intel Covid happened and
[SPEAKER_01]: I still remember when you took me on a, I think it was like the Greenway.
[SPEAKER_01]: It wasn't up around Lake Travis, but it was in Austin.
[SPEAKER_01]: We went shogging, and I was walking.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you were like, well, how far have you gone?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm all like, well, how far have you gone?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're like, well, I think I've gone six miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I think I've only gone six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I want to get back there, you know, hopefully I quit this job soon.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope you all will be happy.
[SPEAKER_01]: We got a good workout bench and the football team, Julian started on his own, I didn't push him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He started football in 8th grade.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then he, like, he asked me why I didn't push him to do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm like, here's your mom.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would have never tolerated me pushing you for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm like, okay, you didn't say anything about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So now, he had a couple friends do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so now, the head of the football scene for the freshman scene at North Midwestern High School, those guys are serious.
[SPEAKER_01]: They've already been, like, sending emails, and they're like, if you play football in eighth grade, you're going to North Medford.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they've got Julian in the gym.
[SPEAKER_01]: After school, three times a week, doesn't waste.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: They started that like last month.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or for next, like, fall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was like, man, these guys are fucking serious.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's been pretty good.
[SPEAKER_00]: You gotta be at that age.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, and he's gonna play, you know, Medford, like when we were at I.D., like he's, Scott's gonna be, I mean, that's a student.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a student in the school.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, yeah, no, he's uh, Jude's gonna be playing in Grand Pass, Roseburg, Eugene.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you still hear me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, I can, I can totally hear you.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's awesome, it sounds like he's uh... Actually, he likes it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I have a course that I'm uh, trying not to be a, you know, I'm conservative, it's liberal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so he acts a little bit, well not a little bit, he actually acts noticeably.
[SPEAKER_01]: He actually refers to Gallagher's capacity.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me scrub a little lightly around that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And at least I tried to compliment that when he said that it was maybe more important than he thought.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's where we left off, I believe.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so, he sailed through the night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And by, I would say dawn, you guys have made it to about there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I see it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, he doesn't seem too concerned.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I am concerned, but I look at him and I say, will we have a fight?
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're in the waters of the Sea Princess now, and patrols never come this far.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're a small sloop.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll look like we're some kind of trading vessel from Port Gordon, or what's less of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something needs to be done, so just let me know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so, you keep sailing...
[SPEAKER_01]: Without, like, you know, trying to seem like an agitator.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, I'll, uh, I'll man a ballista, or, like, you know, use an arrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, by...
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say 8 p.m. you're there, and by 9 p.m. you're there,
[SPEAKER_00]: Sailing up the coast.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: No sign of like, uh, destruction, smoking villages, nothing like that?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's, you know, the coast along the peninsula from Monmurg is actually, you know, very, it's kind of pretty.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are lots of beaches.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, the land up here... Is that a forest or no?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: The land up here are like green rolling hills.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you could see pretty far if there was any kind of like a machine going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: If ENSAR was on fire, you'd see it, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: So basically, as you sail down the coast, he goes, how close do you want me to get you to ENSAR?
[SPEAKER_00]: Shall I let you off two miles to it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Two miles is fine, good man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I'm going to sail by Intars if I was a trader and then dock off maybe in the waters six or seven miles off the coast and wait until nightfall to return to Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you'll have to walk from here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've seen why I was completely lost.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would suggest you say that you come from Let's Keep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, I happen to have Let's Keep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you happen to have?
[SPEAKER_01]: We have some stuff that we cannot carry.
[SPEAKER_01]: You will unload for us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you happen to have a hand cart, perhaps?
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn, that's some fierce stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, I'll give you some poles that you can strap it to.
[SPEAKER_00]: The two of you should be able to carry it up the beach.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look at me, man.
[SPEAKER_01]: I point the part from up where my feet can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have something with wheels?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll pay you an extra ten gold if you can get us worth a half a mile.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's absolutely fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Villagers, as long as they don't compromise your credibility.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no care of what is in Innsar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you have no name on your ship, so you don't need to complain.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we sail to about a half a mile from Innsar, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's obvious that...
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank God.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm like two miles away packing my ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, you know, as he slows the ship,
[SPEAKER_00]: So about half a mile per hour and they got, but he doesn't stop it, and he has a couple of his men get in the longboat and take you across the water to the shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then...
[SPEAKER_01]: I make sure that he has the coinage as I'm getting off into the longboat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you basically pass him the money as you get off onto the longboat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cast the second 50 plus 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, fare thee well in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen Black, is that the only thing that I can tell the captain?
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't forget him.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that the only thing that I can send you a name and a good will towards?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, just remind him
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so the two of you are left on a rocky beach and basically Horace has to shoulder your crate of wine
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, did you take them up on the polls?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: For sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got some things I don't have a minus.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of tough for me, but I can do a half a minus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I mean, you basically have these poles that have ropes on them, and you're able to put the crate between the two of you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, like in a little makeshift rope net or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's only about 75 pounds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I didn't come with a crap ton of stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just, like, maybe a change of clothes that were nice, and...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a small little fishing village and the people basically kind of look at you strangely like whoever you are, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But, you know, obviously they want to stay out of your way, and do their best to basically...
[SPEAKER_00]: The horse is like a burly man-at-arms, and... Burly man-at-arms and some strange-looking ambassador person, uh, there, and who just got dropped off on their beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: They, they kind of looked the other way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I go up to somebody that looks like they are not completely poor or that they have a, you know, 15 sloop or minimum sloop.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there's a, there's a tanner in town.
[SPEAKER_01]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go to the tanner.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the master around?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm he.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank God.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just recently ran the blockade from Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm a horrible hooker.
[SPEAKER_01]: I seek passage to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you perhaps have a wagon, a cart with a donkey, anything that can get me to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: Those tapes.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll sit you in those.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg is 30 miles away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hi.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the donkey.
And the donkey.
[SPEAKER_01]: I love that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, um... Well, if you could take my cart, I'll take you there for two gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Done.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, let me look it up.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can touch my baggage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: The two of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so basically what happens is he hooks everything up and by 11 o'clock you guys are starting to roll down the road towards Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, um...
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he offer anything ahead of time?
[SPEAKER_01]: Two gold coins?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he want a gold coin ahead of time?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you want to give it to him, he'll take it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I'd give him a gold.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unlike the traditional, you know, one gold on, you know, commit and one gold on completion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get me there alive!
[SPEAKER_01]: I asked him also, yeah, how fair is the road?
[SPEAKER_01]: The war with Keoland, you know, I kind of talked all of it, like it's, you know, a big deal, and see if he's like, what the fuck?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, what are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he said, what about the war on Carolina?
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, I assume that's why you had to run the blockade.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aye, oh, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was horrendous.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was terrible.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're here with Red Shores.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've sequestered 40 plus ships of supplies.
[SPEAKER_01]: How fare thee?
[SPEAKER_00]: Monmurg fares not very well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Luckily out here, we're making a killing off the fish that we catch.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why me traveling to Monmurg is not such a bad thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got three barrels that I can sell in the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm, I can sell fish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, do you mind me asking, I've seen that sleep off the coast now several times.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could be the captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: He didn't really give a name.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you need to know it, per se?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, not necessarily.
[SPEAKER_00]: Things are strange, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, those strangers had been smuggled in and dropped off at Ensor, 30 miles away from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you said you were from Red Shore there, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-mm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not from... No, you came from Red Shore, is what you said.
[SPEAKER_01]: I came from Red Shore, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was the late.
[SPEAKER_01]: I come from...
[SPEAKER_01]: And across the room, as you can see, from the A.B., the Iron Maid.
[SPEAKER_00]: So all I wonder is what smugglers can be operating in Red Shore that'd be allowed to be there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do their alliances lie?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, don't smugglers smuggle the coin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't they all profit when there's war?
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm?
[SPEAKER_00]: This be true.
[SPEAKER_01]: He got the stickies sideways and says,
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, your mouth is full of a lot of big names.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look out my window and I... bottles of wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I open it up and I say, this should be full of a lot of names.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've had to use a lot of names to get this far.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I take a big drink and I don't know if I can drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at you and he says, all right.
[SPEAKER_00]: He takes his way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he hands it back to you and he says, No, I hold you no ill will.
[SPEAKER_00]: In truth, I can't tell who is right or who is wrong in this conflict.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or even whose side's who.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you tell me why the Sea Princes have not shattered the Keoland fleet as of yet?
[SPEAKER_01]: I was surprised to be waylaid even near Red Shore as I sailed from Eastern Nigeria.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's my mind that Toli won't let them.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's something strange going on in the sea principalities now.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's strange storms in the bay, and he points out towards the red shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've seen him on the horizon.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yet you say that Toli is somehow in control.
[SPEAKER_00]: All I can tell you is I've seen Toli's ships in between here and Angler Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've seen him out there in the waters.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he basically points back towards this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're hearing about Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, well he's a rich man and fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no ill will towards him.
[SPEAKER_00]: But like I say, who's going to win in this conflict?
[SPEAKER_00]: None for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's something strange happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: And do you see that place where I put the circle?
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, do you see them islands out that way?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can make out on the edge of your sight what looks to be like little clouds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically right on the edge of your ability to see things, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: On the waters about 12 miles is...
[SPEAKER_00]: As far as you can see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, okay, so did I notice those islands when we came down to Ensar?
[SPEAKER_00]: You actually think that you might have seen some low, low, you know, there are islands out in the bay, definitely, but small ones.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you might have noticed some out that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he points back out, so he actually draws my attention to what maybe I had suspected was there, but we kind of skirt.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did we skirt east of those islands?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well, you skirted like this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay, okay, that's what I was thinking.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he points out to a spot that we barely skirted, but that it actually tickles my memory a little bit, like maybe there were some clouds over
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, you didn't really see anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it was kind of a moonless night, so everything was kind of dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I look at where he's pointing, and I say, well, even if those are islands in the bay, what do they have to do with the Toli?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, the four princes rule north.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what some say, but things are strange now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Apparently, a Toli princeling took stewardship of the fort out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of those islands has a fort on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was made many years ago, maybe 150 years ago, to fight the sahaugin that infested these waters.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, there's a Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: A Toli set that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who gave the Toli, uh...
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that's a Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Money will buy anything in the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: I seek money for the war across the Azur Sea and the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_01]: Money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell her that.
[SPEAKER_00]: All I can say is I've seen ships come and go freely from there.
[SPEAKER_01]: To Ensar or to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: All over the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And is Port Torvin truly destroyed?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah yes, Port Torvin is destroyed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Burned to the ground by Captain Grimson.
[SPEAKER_00]: Grimson?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, Captain Grimson.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he a killender?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or a rogue pirate?
[SPEAKER_00]: By all accounts, he's a Toli rat.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, they say he works for the... Commandant of this new place called Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Steve, you're getting things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's a little better.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I offered him a drink from my newly opened bottle of Chardonnay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I have two unopened bottles, just so we're clear.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, no, and we drank on our way there, and if I can fly him for more information about why Monmurg has not soured forth or about the Toli
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, he basically says, you know, he tells you that, you know, a Toli princeling has taken residence there and has ships, several ships that sail to and from that island a lot, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And he sees them actually sailing freely around in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, are they landing in Ansar, or do they have a smuggler's coat somewhere?
[SPEAKER_01]: You asking that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, they're not smuggling.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're doing something else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Praise hell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keepin' out a tight lip.
[SPEAKER_00]: All I know is when the Monmurgian navy tries to sally forth, you see ships from that island leaving the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was Prince of Toli's name.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well...
[SPEAKER_01]: I will pay you good, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will pay you a gold coin for his name.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Excuse me, Cain Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he has manned the islands in the middle of the day.
[SPEAKER_01]: South of Anger Island, north of Ansar, in the middle of the day.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do I hear you good, sir, correctly, that he, well, excuse me,
[SPEAKER_01]: That there are mysterious happenings whenever Monmurg does sally forth.
[SPEAKER_01]: You said sally forth.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Monmurgian fleet has sally forth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, they turn twice, aye.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twice?
[SPEAKER_01]: In numbers?
[SPEAKER_00]: In numbers.
[SPEAKER_00]: The squadron.
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what happened?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did any of the squadron return?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've heard that the squadron did return, but for some reason were beaten off.
[SPEAKER_00]: In those same few days, I've seen the fleet from Ingl...
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, not from Anglo-Ireland.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've seen the fleet from the port, Shelleyport itself, and sailed to the east.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then a strange storm would brew.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're in the same region, just north of Monmurg, between Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: That be true.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sir, I am not a captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know not of the natives.
[SPEAKER_01]: How much of you say of these waters?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you fish deep in the bay?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've made it to the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know the force there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've gone that far.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have to understand there's an atoll out there, rich with fish, even though there's areas where there's blight.
[SPEAKER_00]: The coral's dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can see the bones of the sahaugin at the bottom of the sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, this to the DM.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, how many people are on this, uh, like, is it just me and one man?
[SPEAKER_01]: And, and Horton.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, just me and Horton.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Horton.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will pay you to talk to Sir Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pay me to talk to Lord Jamis?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, of what you tell.
[SPEAKER_01]: I entreat thee.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will pay the extra and ensure your safe return.
[SPEAKER_01]: You fear not, but you must be able to communicate these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am not of the sea, and I do not know of Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: My patron is aware of these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: A man as powerful as Lord Jamis knows these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will
[SPEAKER_01]: He be none the less.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if he knows these things, then there is no fear for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you say, he knows these.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am a year from these shores.
[SPEAKER_01]: A year ago I had left.
[SPEAKER_01]: I return and there is a state of war.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I am Lord Jamis' man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rest assured, in having returned to these shores, I
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll tell you what.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell Lord Jamis I am, um, loyal to Prince Jeon, that I'll continue to watch.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if he wishes, he could set up a writer, and I could tell him when the Toli sell it forth.
[SPEAKER_00]: In good taste, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: But in truth, I'm sure that a man as important and as well-connected as Lord Jamis knows all that I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so to the DM, I make sure, like, you know, he's the Tanner.
[SPEAKER_01]: I make sure I know his name.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to be able to tell Lord Jamis, like, exactly all the details of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh-huh.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so that, like, Lord Jamis knows that when I speak of it, and he says that he's, like, Lord Jamis' man, that this can be facilitated.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you guys continue on.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes strangely silent.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you guys ride the rest of the way to the gates of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, these are the outer gates.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there he stops.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And says, Do you have my other gold?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I give him his second gold.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he says,
[SPEAKER_00]: So when do you go speak to Lord Jamis?
[SPEAKER_01]: I will speak to Lord Jamis as soon as you entertain me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so this is, you get to the gates at around 6 p.m.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, it takes you about eight hours to do the trip from Intar to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're getting there on, I would say this is 8 p.m. on the first of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, what would I like to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Am I incorrect?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jamis works late.
[SPEAKER_01]: He always works late.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you know where his office is, and most likely he is late.
[SPEAKER_00]: He will work late.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I need to get into, at least, present to his establishment?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I need to pay anybody?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, I can enter the porn quarter, no problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so what I would do is this, is that we pay the guy, he goes back to Ensar, and I would tell Forrest, be like, nice coach, or, you know, straight taxi or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to send Horace to Perth?
[SPEAKER_01]: Really?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's in a shitty part of town.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, like, the Boren District is not a nice part of town.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, like, aren't we all only allowed in the Boren District?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, no, you can walk through the Great Market.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Monmurg is basically Four Hills, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And in the middle is the Great Market.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's all walled.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then the poor district is a district that is kind of next to, it's below the outer walls on the hills, basically on shoreline.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there are docks there and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: But then there are the great docks, which is where Lord Jamis is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Sham is as far as I understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: He controls the docks, but also the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he does.
[SPEAKER_00]: He controls the security of both.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then the foreign district has like a main path that goes into the Great Market, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But all of the Great Market, the foreign district, and the harbor district are all basically not on the hills, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so what I want to do is, is, I don't want to send horror, so it's like a cartload of like 500 gold and a fucking ship that's going to get jacked up on.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if I understand Monmurg right, if it is most advantageous or most safe to just demand
[SPEAKER_01]: An audience with Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nobody's going to remember me after this fucking year.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get that.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I have to grease some palms, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if I keep greasing some palms on my way up to Lord Jamis' office with intensity, that's what I'm going to push for.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like this, like now, within like so many minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so the thing is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: You could probably walk through the main gates
[SPEAKER_00]: Present in this scene.
[SPEAKER_01]: Present in this scene.
[SPEAKER_00]: Conscious, but wouldn't we actually do this one?
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like you to be conscious too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so this is a good stopping point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's stop here.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're right outside the gates of Monmurg at 6 p.m. and you're about to enter the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: The gates are still open if you're about to enter the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, in fact, when you left last, it was because Karma was banished.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fucker stole the book about training dogs.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was actually from Greyhawk, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No!
[SPEAKER_01]: That was from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fucking training dogs.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I actually get to meet Derek, I'm gonna slap him in the face.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, man.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, I love you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you recording these?
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, I'm recording all of those.
[SPEAKER_00]: Love you too, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I want to hear more about your kids.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll definitely show you some of these.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Take care.
[SPEAKER_01]: Talk to you later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you give me an exclusive one?
[SPEAKER_00]: I will.